everybody have a good time hey everybody
everybody hello hey everybody everybody
have a good time
hey everybody everybody hello welcome to
the podcast
my name is Bobbi we've got Gilbert
kalila and George and we're brought to
you live from the sunny beaches of San
Diego at the PB bar and grill
everything's great everything's sunny
and everything's positive I feel great
about this week and last week didn't
happen last podcast didn't happen at all
and this is a new me and your wife and
we're having fun and we're on the sunny
beaches of San Diego and we got $2 beer
margarita is on sale and today I want to
start off with a new segment I like to
call learning stuff everybody likes to
learn stuff do they not yes do they not
raise your hands if you like to learn
stuff and I want to talk to today about
colors colors Oh colors like colors you
have primary colors correct
what are those yellow blue was right now
yes yeah it is sir thank you it is
Gabriel that is a primary color but
they're all there I don't know if you
guys know this but there are offshoots
of the colors and and yeah it's they're
very specific ones too you've got some
ones that kind of look grey called like
slave slate grey yeah that's a nice one
right that's what I want to focus on the
Browns today okay if you focus on the
brown colors and my favorite color of
the Browns is sandal brown brown what
does that look and I'll tell you what it
looks like the color of kalila [ __ ] in
the toilet laughter this is a fun fact
the whole time she didn't flush the
[ __ ] toilet I go into the bathroom
and I see a piece of [ __ ] that was it
was been for so long you know how it
breaks away Gabriel got hard no it broke
away so it was like different floats so
Sophos often the levee broke look like
the levee broke so that's my toilet oh
so flush it [ __ ] okay everybody
everybody have a good time
hey everybody everybody hello now listen
give me a panic attack
sorry good here's another thing okay
alright here's another thing is this
that I do not and I'm trying to be
positive this week and I'm trying to be
a good guy like charlie was a good guy
I want to be a good guy yet no but even
a better guy than that guy okay but I
want to be positive all right and so um
if you live in my house I really need
you to have a strong core what do you
think a strong abdominal core I have
that poor and a strong heart and
strength okay and you when you watch a
trailer for a cartoon
you don't cry what happened well last
night I'm sitting next to my lovely lady
and she's watching trailers on the
YouTube or whatever and she sees a
trailer for the Beauty and the Beast and
about 30 seconds into the trailer she
starts crying you don't understand you
don't like you don't what was I'm giving
you I'm giving you an opportunity to
sway us TED talk it's a sensitive
subject for me I I don't know it just
reminded me of my dad I'm sorry it was
supposed to be everybody hello success I
know but no I am I watch this new Beauty
and the Beast trailer and I the song
that for Angela Lansbury er these things
it's a mean Beauty and the Beast huh um
hit me in a way I didn't expect and I
started crying for three hours
she cried like it was nine 12 the day
after 9/11 I'm a she cried as if it was
a national tragedy I don't know what hit
me how it hit me why it hit me that way
it just did and I couldn't stop crying
and I couldn't stop laughing I left I
cackle for a solid 20 minutes and then
after my cackling she come over here to
hug me I go nope and I left the room
because in my house you need a strong
core and you're strong you guess what
crying is strong no it's not yes it is
and fill the house on sand and my
grandfather taught me that all right you
need to solve it
and is made of constant constant
pressure from the water right exactly
right yes so but my tears are the water
it's not the water and this is how sand
is made in this house okay mm-hm maybe
in your house because your house is
where you come from or made out of
[ __ ] bamboo no they're made out of
NEPA NEPA is a very strong strong tree
don't cry over cartoons [ __ ] in my
house and that's all I wanted to say
everybody hi hi everybody
[Music]